we're gonna watch this heavily requested
video I've been taking the time to go
through comments to see what's been like
the most requested today is a day of
anime apparently today is one punch man
live-action trailer Saitama versus jenos
reanimates comes from the channel
reanimate a channel I've never seen hey
this is heavily requested so if you guys
end up liking this video I mean hit the
like button more importantly make sure
to subscribe to these guys and I'm sure
they'll deserve it because of the fact
that this is so friggin requested I've
seen all the one punch man Season one at
our patreon but we could talk more about
that later he was in store
[Music]
don't
I want you to take it very seriously
nothing about black square okay
[Music]
oh my god
oh yes thank you patron supporters I
hope you have more than just those seven
because obviously deserve much more oh
man fan films these days are the
absolute best this is pretty incredible
because the idea of like doing Saitama
and bringing him to life is a lot more
feasible it's a lot easier to imagine
you get the right costume the right
looking bald actor and store and Saitama
is always bored it has that dry delivery
and then right there's like okay it
doesn't really care has this emotionless
detachment demeanor about it but then
with jenos bringing the human cyborg to
life yeah that's really impressive stuff
and I love that with the visual effects
Department you didn't lead with one
punch man you led with a cool Genesis
maneuver what's to come in store I mean
but like looking at the visual effects
of that with the Lightning the rocks
exploding the big fire in the background
this just looks so epic and then of
course like when the arms have like the
big fire extending from like the bicep
tricep area it looks so freakin epic we
always talk about this any time people
do fan films or short films or
especially fight scenes it's usually in
like a park area and in hiking trail
yeah that's the way to do it right I
mean they're using it to their best
advantage they're gonna be covering up
with special effects so yeah at least
distract somewhat but yeah at least from
the glimpses I have caught of the show
and the characters there's always a
certain tension with live-action anime
as to how is this gonna translate
especially when were you know capturing
looks and whatnot yeah I just loved his
got the glowing eyes and the black
sclera convincing mists of the effects
was nice to see because especially now
like you see prosumer equipment and
people are doing more and more and more
impressive things on a DIY scale and
then you jump to that shot at the end
which does look like one of those anime
splash frame
where you know you have all that it's
all you need is those jittery lines on
the edges of the frame you know that
they draw in but yeah this is this got
me really excited and it gets me excited
for the future down the road
of maybe we'll finally get that
agreeably good live-action anime movie
but then for your next anime action
short film of one punch man can't do it
at the park now you got to go to a
metropolis space city like how a lot of
the show does it okay and then next time
you could go into the sky in space can't
wait to see cuz it's always one punch
that's the thing John it's one punch it
small sight - money can't wait to see
what that one punch looks like in this
short film then I can't wait to see what
you guys do when you're destroying
buildings and whatnot and your next one
do it practical effects do it practical
yeah as much as you can especially now
now's the time to do it they might not
even notice go do it on location Yeah
right tickle everything yeah guys
subscribe to re anime and you can
subscribe to our channel and click our
notification bell and actually over at
our patreon we have a weekly QA podcast
and that's where you guys submit you
know a question and then we take a few
of them we make a full podcast out of
them so you can check us out over there
as well as the main thing which is our
TV show reactions so we do TV show
reaction watch lungs and reaction
highlights included that we edit
ourselves for shows such as attack on
Titan Jon just finished a promised
Neverland my hero academia finished that
the two heroes movie included Death Note
almost done with code geass Hunter
hunter midway through season 3 first
season a one-punch man Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood JoJo's bizarre
adventures Doctor Who and supernatural
and then their shows we do only watch
along for them than watch long meaning
you sink over the time code that's what
I mean by that those shows that we do
Gotham agents of shield there's quite
there's quite a few there's a there's a
lot over there last but not least I'd
like to end this without
Victoria Huntley and Erica Tuesday so
lately we once in a while will do these
fan fiction stories of what if this
patron met this patron and John wrote
this one which is always what you want
to hear which is always good news this
is gonna make sense I haven't read it I
never do this is the most grounded one
yet
Oh what makes the most sense it has the
most recurring jokes that are
intelligible and it's actually gonna
represent or represent them hey the
people love a good fantasy I'll actually
be like oh yeah that's that's making fun
of them directly
all right let's let's see what's in
store see all right oh you played both
of them before oh you have to read the
whole thing
I don't you uh out of the Erica this
time okay I'll be Victoria this will be
even better
exterior San Diego Convention Center
alternate universe de Victoria
cosplaying as a gender bent Greg stands
in front of the convention hall glass
futzing with her hair just then a gender
bent John with a big paper mache head
approaches it's Erica Tuesday
you missed the curl on the back there
what where Victoria realizes who she's
looking at wow that's a really accurate
John costume Erica takes the head off
revealing a painted beard and long wig
thanks man I made it myself you do a
pretty great Greg Victoria takes a huge
ripoff for ecig and smashes a beanie
onto her head Thanks it's a shame not
enough people here dresses the
world-famous real rejects here at San
Diego comic-con this year it's my week
and yet I've seen at least 300 Gordon's
since breakfast alone it's weird right
seriously we got to reach in Tyler hey
it's another picture of her yeah she's
got a funny way of talking it's kind of
like he's not she's cool you know script
is going off tangent no one could even
follow the season award it's only on
page boy seriously we gotta let the
reject nation know they're being
represented out here in these nerdy
comic-con streets
that's a Greg cellent idea Shawn right
it is but how well we can start doing
library
look at this place there's tons of stuff
to gawk guffaw and cringe at John does
love that cringe face that's what he
mainly does this is Gregg speaking
scroll down he sure does what is that
anyway like is it a pain smile are you
trying not to laugh do you just find a
lot of things that uncomfortable
what's with the look John Ericka looks
down for a moment crestfallen sorry
classic John you think so
I've been practicing apologizing for
most everything all week it shows I
really believed it was the eighth or
ninth time you've said that this morning
Thanks and you haven't put that
e-cigarette down since we started
talking
Victoria blows a fatty cloud thank you
you know we make a pretty great team we
do I think we should start our own Greg
and John tribute channel but we react to
things dressed as Greg and John exactly
I've always wanted to be referred to as
Jerry even though they gave up the
pseudonyms literally years ago at this
point
oh dude I've been called Ryan right at
least a dozen times since rolling in
here
well let's say we go find us one of
those knockoff Andrews and get this show
on the road
that's an album of a plan Erica Tuesday
damn right mother Humphrey I think this
is the beginning of a beautiful
friendship dude and so Victoria and
Erica R embarked on a lifelong journey
creating their own real rejects tribute
channel that would go on to outstrip the
actual real rejects in both overall
numbers and popularity the end and he
wrote a story about Greg and joy
well you know you know Erica personally
I know what these are fictional scenes
where they're meeting each other I'm
like okay well I got I just throw in
some information about her specifically
okay let me know if this one sucked
Erica Victoria you do the same piece
you